foreign
[Music]
there's nothing down there
we made sure of that
what do you got there
this old [__] is a gold miner
you got gold in those bags
take a look at this
we're rich boys
no no
you're dead
that's
get down on your knees
bags are full of gold
[Laughter]
get down on your knees Grandpa
shoot the [__]
[__] him up
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we got gold
no
thank you
fire
the general he has given us orders
turn back
and head to Norway from Finland
immediately
did you tell him he just killed seven of
our men I did
and
he thinks we were lucky
[__] lucky
the dog tags belong to a man named after
me Corby
he was a Finnish Commando
the most feared in his unit
the general said
and I quote
he's one mean [__] that you do
not want to mess with
he fought in the winter War
lost his home and his family to the
Russians
he became a ruthless vengeful soldier
who took orders from no one
he fiends they gave up trying to
discipline or control him
they just sent him out alone Into the
Wilderness to hunt Russian Patrols
he became a one-man Death Squad
[Music]
the reports are unconfirmed but it looks
like he has over 300 Russian kills
the Russians
they gave him a name
they call him koshai
the immortal
immortal
foreign
[Music]
this son of a [__] is still alive
shoot the man
shoot the dog too
all right
[Music]
ah
get off the house
this old [__] is a gold miner
we're rich boys
get down on your knees
[__] him up
we got gold
ah
it was a Finnish Commander lost his home
and his family in the war he became a
one-man Death Squad
[Music]
he's one mean [__] that you do
not want to mess with
[Music]
fire
you'll see what happens when you take
everything from him
they really believe that he's Immortal
no he just refuses to die how many Minds
did you bury here all of them
you
and you
this is not about who's the strongest
this is about not giving up
we have a word for that in Finland
thank you
we might have a problem
[Music]